we begin today with an alarming new
milestone right here in America New York
State now has more reported coronavirus
cases than any country in the world let
that sink in for just a second and new
pictures are a disturbing reminder of
the human toll of that this is a mass
grave being dug for coronavirus victims
at New York City's potter's field where
unclaimed bodies are laid to rest yeah
it's a reminder there that the poorest
and most marginal are bearing the
greatest burden in this crisis and it's
a widening crisis more than four hundred
and sixty-six thousand covered cases
reported nationwide and the death toll
is now well above sixteen thousand but
there are signs of improvement hospital
admissions from the virus are declining
in new york and california two of the
hardest hit States our lead national
correspondent David Beck now is here in
New York at the US Naval Hospital ship
the comfort David good morning so we've
been hearing about deadliest days in New
York for several days in a row but we
may be hearing we may we may be hitting
a turning point turning a corner how so
well maybe so totally and let me tell
you why in speaking with one of the
commanders here on the ship yesterday I
said to him how come you've only treated
100 patients or so when you have
capacity for so much more and he said
sir we're just not getting that many
patients coming to us the need doesn't
exist so we called the governor's office
and the governor's office told us this
there are 90,000 hospital beds statewide
because they've had to add so many in
recent weeks but only 18,000 of them are
actually filled so yeah this is really
good news but every time we get good
news like that it seems to always be
said right alongside something that is
stunning like this
so many people are dying in New York
City due to coronavirus complications
that the morgues are crowded to the
point where new graves are being dug off
Hart island near the Bronx crews are
burying unclaimed bodies that have been
at the board for more than two weeks
still the state's new hospitalizations
are the lowest they have been since the
coronavirus crisis started and ICU
admissions are at their lowest level in
more than three weeks all of this data
suggests that we are flattening the
curve so far and that's why one place
that was supposed to be a field hospital
is scaling back beds had been set up two
days ago at this Manhattan Cathedral
they've now been packed away meanwhile
logistical issues appear to be part of
the reason why the five hundred bed
hospital ship comfort has treated only
80 patients so far what do you say to
people in Manhattan who are looking at
this thing you got this big beautiful
ship with a lot of room and it's
practically empty the optics may not be
great we've been working with again the
city of New York
FEMA any disaster emergency response
takes a little bit from a coordination
perspective there are moments of joy
happening around the country in Missouri
87 year old Don Locke Miller has
survived the corona virus he spent ten
days in the hospital and is now home but
the virus continues to spread in places
in the Midwest in Michigan the number of
deaths in a single day was expected to
peak on Thursday Detroit nurse Jennifer
Rocco says she saw three bodies taken to
the morgue in one shift it's a bad day
but unfortunately there are days that
that has become a normal in Flint
Michigan sandy brown lost her husband
Freddie Brown jr. and her 20 year old
son Freddie the third they both died
from the corona virus in a span of just
three days they are two of four
parishioners from pastor Kimba Nolan's
church that died this month I guess
speechless you know I get a little
emotional because of the effects that is
happening in in America but then didn't
come again
it is in the black community Freddie the
third had hoped to walk on to the
Michigan State football team his dad
helped to organize church services
here's an example of our new normal in
America sandy will bury her husband and
her son today groundsmen that the
cemetery will carry their caskets to the
grave while sandy is asked to sit in her
car and watch Anthony David thank you